[Music]
right can't believe my entire
sixth-grade class is here what a
surprise
I've been hanging out with my childhood
friend and she has children and it's one
of the things that bring me so much joy
to see a parent and child when a
firetruck is approaching you hear the
siren and the mother is like a fire
truck fire truck like it's like a fire
truck yeah a fire truck
so exciting but let's not forget what is
going on on the other side of this siren
there is a horrible tragedy find your
truck one clap thank you no one at a
time
my trip I travel everywhere and I've
noticed over the past a year or two the
these signs are popping up at public
pools stating that you cannot go
swimming if you have diarrhea and it it
makes sense I understand it's a you know
there's disease but who what kind of
person is that comfortable with
themselves so where they're like not
feeling very well today
doctor says probably stay home but you
know what I'm gonna head down to the
public pool go do some laps really how
comfortable do you have to be to just be
doing the backstroke with full-on
diarrhea out of the pool you can't swim
with diarrhea how am I supposed to know
this
yeah out you cannot swim if you don't
want me swimming with diarrhea you're
gonna have to put a sign up
there is no way there's no way to know
that was more than one clap leave it to
my childhood buddies here's a little
tidbit about me I was diagnosed with
bilateral breast cancer and I ended up
getting a double mastectomy and before I
had a double mastectomy I was already
pretty flat-chested and I made so many
jokes over the years about how small my
chest was that I started to think that
maybe my boobs overheard me and we're
just like you know what we're sick of
this let's kill her
side are you on
take her down before I go I want to give
you a gift it's something that I like to
do to friends of mine and I want you to
use it I like to send text messages to
friends of mine at random times of the
day that just say what's your ETA I love
knowing somewhere across town somebody's
frantically rifling through emails and
text messages in their underwear trying
to figure out what they agreed to do
with me they write back what and I write
yeah we're all seated better hurry then
they write back where and don't respond
again delete them from your phone
your life thanks so much
[Applause]